a deliberately developmental
organization is first of all a mouthful
so we call it ad do for short and it's
sort of an answer to the question if an
organization so valued developing the
capabilities of its people that it would
want to create a culture that could
immersively gather every member of that
culture into an ongoing developmental
personal kind of learning journey what
would that culture look like what would
such an organization look like and
that's what we set out to discover and
you know in the process what we learned
is that in the ordinary organization
most people are doing a second job that
nobody's paying them for and that second
job has to do with looking good hiding
their weaknesses covering their
inadequacies managing other people's
favorable impressions of them and you
can say that's a human nature but it
also turns out to be incredibly costly
in ways that we don't think enough about
if I keep hiding my weaknesses the
likelihood that I'm gonna overcome them
shrinks to near zero and the
organization has to keep essentially
paying for the consequences of my
limitations and they're paying me a
full-time salary for part-time work so
imagine an organization where people
would feel safe enough that they would
they would kind of consider they were
hired not because anybody thought they
were perfect but because people thought
they were good and that they could learn
and that one of their jobs there you
know is to learn and where you get
actually supported for you know
revealing your mistakes and you could
say that kind of there's kind of an
entrepreneurial
stance toward people development you
know the watchword of entrepreneurialism
is not to avoid failure but to fail
frequently
at to fail fast and to fail forward so
imagine a culture where people were
encouraged to do that so that they would
keep learning and getting better and
then you would be imagining a DDO a
deliberately developmental organization
I think another really important feature
of these cultures that anyone would
quickly notice if you spent a little
time in them is a kind of transparency a
way in which people and often the way
they'll say it is I am Who I am
at work in other words they're not
living a divided life this is what we
mean by this notion that in ordinary
organizations we're all doing a second
job we're trying to look good we're
always trying to kind of be at our best
in these organizations that quickly gets
seen as a way of essentially avoiding
one of the most precious and valuable
things that the culture has to offer you
which is the opportunity to just be the
same person at work that you are when
you're not at work and that means you
know the good the bad and what you might
think is the ugly bridgewater talks
about this as radical transparency and
that means that you know in the ordinary
ordinary organization everybody agrees
it's unprofessional to talk critically
about people behind their backs and
everybody participates in it and some of
you listening right now are thinking I
don't do that okay you may not be a
speaker but I bet you've been a listener
to such communications and you didn't
say to the other person
I think it's unprofessional and wrong
for you to be talking about Ralph
to be behind his back so one way or the
other passively
are actively we have all participated in
what we know to be unprofessional
you know behavior in bridgewater there
is no back to be behind why because hold
on to your hats in every office and in
every meeting room there's tape
recording equipment and every
conversation is being tape recorded not
in a creepy NSA kind of way but if I'm
having a conversation if if you report
to me and I'm having a conversation with
you I have another conversation about
you with my boss and you're not in the
room so I've now been talking about you
you don't have to fair through 400 tapes
and see if somebody mentioned your name
I have an obligation send you an email
and let you know you were discussed you
know in this meeting you know at
such-and-such a time on such-and-such a
day feel free if you want to listen to
the tape so there's absolutely I know it
drives people you know people get very
struck you know by this but you know
it's just one of a number of features
that quickly give you the sense we're
talking about a whole different way of
being at work
you